fentanyl overdoses a raging border
crisis soaring crime President Obama
being criticized after revealing that
none of those issues are the ones that
keep him up at night
what about this country keeps you up at
night
the thing that I'm most worried about is
the degree to which
we now have a divided conversation
in part because we have a divided media
when I was coming up you had three TV
stations yeah and people were getting a
similar sense of what is true and what
isn't what was real and what was not
today what I'm most concerned about is
the fact that because of the splintering
of the media we almost occupy different
realities while President Obama worries
about people living in different
realities The Washington Post announcing
that it is standing by it's Trump Russia
collusion investigation coverage even
after the Durham report blew a hole in
the mainstream media's reporting that is
something else Jesse that is something
else yeah I am standing by my birth
certificate reporting
take it back and take it back I do take
it back
um so Barack Obama has been whining
about fox for what now 10 years and he
has 90 control of the media but Fox
keeps him up at night not all of the
mass shootings in Chicago uh not
Michelle Fox you know the guy never
wants to talk about policy he never
talks about policy it's always PR with
him and he's so thin-skinned and there
has to be something really deeper than
all of this he's probably a little
annoyed that Joe Biden's passing better
legislation than he is he's annoyed that
Michelle is a fruit juice Tycoon and has
her own Netflix special and her book
sold more copies and he's looking for
attention because you're asking the
former president this is a pretty
important question you're looking for a
Visionary response this was not you know
in a hundred years you know we're
talking about AI keeps me up China no
it's just seawater's prime time yeah
polarization in America that is like the
pat answer I had no idea he was a white
supremacist he wants to go back to the
days where you have three white TV
anchors right men so it's really it is
kind of an interesting observation that
among the left racism has exploded as
more and more diverse voices are all
over the place it's like you've seen
minority majority rule basically in
entertainment and it's now worse than
ever what is wrong with a divided media
we have a divided government it's the
only way things can work is is to have
now there is division intense division
that's different than a divided media
right you know people getting angry at
each other demonizing people uh
generally the demonization the
demonization started with the left
because they were the ones who made it
personal uh in the 70s and now the
rights catching up but you need to have
a divided media because what else would
you have you would have the three white
guys uh you know and everything sucked
in the 70s the only good thing you could
do is litter and basically I learned
that was wrong too over time and you can
smoke and smoking smoke everywhere and
then you could go up to the
drive-through you could order food and
then you would just throw everything out
the window we were crazy people back
then you don't want to go back there
Katie it was his staff that coined the
phrase media Echo chamber when Ben
Rhodes if you remember uh did the story
that said basically they were able to
push any narrative they wanted to
because the media that they were talking
to would eat it up specifically with the
Iran nuclear deal
um President Obama talks about how we
have a divided media that we live in
different realities that's a problem for
him we actually just have a fuller
picture because we have more media we
have democratized media through
alternative stations through social
media through citizen journalists and
yet people like President Obama don't
like that because it debunks a number of
these narratives that they continue to
try and push let's not forget that
Barack Obama was the president who spied
on reporters he was tapping the phones
of news Executives they're following the
movements of reporters going in and out
of federal government buildings they
prosecuted more sources under the
Espionage Act than any other president
in the history of the country and you
wonder if we were still doing this 3
three you know the three Network thing
big scandals like operation Fast and
Furious for example wouldn't have been
covered just think about all the things
that don't get covered by certain
Outlets but do get covered by others and
so we have a fuller store well it's
interesting if you do think about the
hunter Biden laptop story The mainstream
media got dragged Kicking and Screaming
to admitting that that story was real
after a while it definitely took a while
it was not that we're going to rehash
everything from the illustrious Twitter
files but it was like 24 hours that the
story was down when the New York Post
put it up but yeah there are definitely
some things where the media is late to
the game on it and there seems to be in
a you know a wink and a nod agreement
like we're not talking about this these
are the things that are our priorities
and that's really what your media choice
is about you find something that
reflects the things that you care about
so if you're a voter or you're just a
person maybe you're not even that
political that thinks that what's going
on on the border is absolutely the most
important story you're going to tune
into whether that's an influencer that's
some want to as a YouTube show a podcast
a Cable News Network that is going to
cover those stories because that's what
resonates with you we talk about this
all the time but candidates go out there
and they talk about things that just
don't mean anything to the to Their
audience right you show up in the wrong
place we were saying about the town hall
last week right that Caitlin Collins
wanted to talk about issues that might
matter to CNN voters but the Republican
primary voters that were sitting there
saying you know actually I'm not showing
up because I want to talk about the jobs
decision I want to talk about illegal
immigration or I want to talk about uh
police slain police officers
um Jesse to your point though about
President Obama being jealous of Joe
Biden the Affordable Care Act
which he got passed is one of the most
seminal pieces of legislation in America
yeah seminal means I do do you I don't
think you know what it means I dare you
to tell all of us what it means no it's
to write it off I'm the one writing it
off
b-f-d
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else